this is the s95 QR Soundbar and this has
an entire system and I'm so hyped to set
this up the installation of this thing
was so easy it was actually kind of
mind-blowing I went in and turned on the
wow interface and this will allow you to
be able to use one remote and control
each separate speaker just right here on
the TV so here you can see it brought up
all of the settings and you can see all
of our speakers individually this TV and
sound bar are made to work together in
perfect synchronization which might not
be the case if you're using a soundar
from a different manufacturer so the
fact that this is made by L and made
specifically for this TV it's going to
sound amazing speaking of sounding
amazing let's test it out it sounds so
incredible what's so special about Wild
Orchestra is that not only does the
audio come out of the surrounding
speakers and the Soundbar but it's also
coming out of the TV at the same time
this is really unique because usually
most sound bars and surround sound
systems will just replace the audio
coming out of the TV but this works with
it to enhance your sound even more